to election news now election day is
just over a week away
and the presidential race is kicking
into high gear here in nevada
singer cher is backing joe biden at
campaign events in las vegas this
weekend
orca mana joins us live near russell and
fort apache tonight
where cher just took the stage orco
well sasha superstar in las vegas
mainstay cher
is throwing her full support behind joe
biden she along with congresswoman
suzy lee addressed a crowd of about more
than a hundred supporters
here tonight the event here actually
just wrapped up in the last 15 minutes
the main message go out and vote now
sharon was met with some
serious applause from those supporters
when she first walked on stage
and it's important to note that cher is
being very clear that she is not a
stranger to political activism she
talked about the importance of all
eligible nevadans
exercising their right to vote in this
election and why she believes joe biden
is the best person to be president
she as well as congresswoman lee touched
on issues like the economy
and health care by the way early voting
is still underway across the state
and will wrap up on october 30th and
election day is just 10 days away
today is actually early vote day and
cher says making your voice heard
is crucial i want us to have some power
and i want people to have a good
living wage and i want women to get help
when they have
children
in response to cher's visit the trump
team put a spin on the singer's lyric
saying in part quote
joe biden would turn back time to the
days of record unemployment and home
foreclosures
nevadans can feel something inside them
say they really don't think
joe biden is strong enough now cher has
even more campaign events for joe biden
in the valley tomorrow tomorrow morning
she will be
joining the lgbtq community for a motor
voter mobilization rally and then we'll
kick off a
virtual canvassing event with volunteers
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now